hey Guardians the destiny to beta is now
available for all to shoot and loot
their way through the game's opening
story mission a strike and some hot PvP
while the beta might not be quite as
extensive as the one for the original
destiny there is still a lot we were
able to learn from our time with it if
you end up enjoying this video make sure
to give us a like and sub because we're
sure to have plenty more destiny content
down the road before the game launches
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
shaders in the original destiny were a
great way to make your guardian feel
unique but they were limited to presets
and you couldn't get crazy with the
customization poking around in destiny
two's menus you can now see that shaders
can be applied to individual pieces of
armor and not just armor but also
weapons your ghosts and even your ship
exotics seem to be the exception maybe
because Bungie still plans on using the
ornament system that was added in Rise
of iron in addition to changing the look
of your gun you can also customize
certain weapons both energy and power
weapons have mod slots meaning you can
swap a solar mod for an ark mod that
fits their play style this opens up a
lot of possibilities and saves some
headache where in destiny 1 you would
need a certain damage type but it
happened to be on a gun you didn't like
now you can just swap around and you're
good
the beta strike the inverted spire is
actually pretty open-ended at the
beginning with a decent amount of
explorable space to it
considering how a lot of strikes in the
first destiny would start in the free
roam areas before leading to a strike
specific location this is probably true
for the inverted spire this means you
get a taste of what the patrol area for
the planet of necess will be like it's
pretty empty though in its current beta
form so don't expect to find much but
some smart destiny players have already
glitched their way through some
unfinished areas we clearly weren't
meant to find
[Music]
in the beta you get access to all three
classes there are old subclasses with
some changes and new subclasses perhaps
the biggest overall change for the
classes is a new third universal ability
that each class has regardless of their
subclass the Titan gets the brand new
Sentinel subclass with the ability to
form a void shield and throw it at
people like Captain America and at
ricochets you start with only one throw
but can upgrade it to two and if you
happen to miss the bubble from destiny
ones defender class don't worry you can
still make one the strikers fists of
havoc is pretty similar but you can now
shoulder charge enemies while your super
is active the Titans Universal ability
either lets them create a large barrier
to protect themselves or a small barrier
that when taking cover behind reloads
their weapon
since Destiny's reveal we've already
seen a good amount of the Warlocks new
class the dawn blade which lets you
float in the air and throw blades of
light at people a fun trick we learned
is that you can do a mid-air dodge
similar to be Twilight garrison exotic
chess piece in d1 which was originally
only for Titans the void Walker class
has a small change with its super the
nova bomb which now tracks enemies and
will send out a little accion bolts when
it lands the warlocks new universal
ability lets them create a field that
will heal both themselves and teammates
the hunters new arc starter class is a
replacement for the Blade Dancer and
it's super serves a similar function but
now has a bit more range to it the
changes are a little more
behind-the-scenes though where by
combining it with your dodge ability you
can choose to either keep your combo
going longer or dish out more damage
this gives the arc staff more variety in
how to use it the gunslingers big change
is that fast players can now shoot up to
6 times with the Golden Gun
instead of the normal three and you can
upgrade it for even more shots if you
get a precision hit the universal
ability for the hunter is a McCree style
dodge roll which you can either reload
your weapon with or recharge your melee
those are a few of the things we found
while playing destiny choose beta if you
found anything cool debated that excites
you throw it in those comments we also
have plenty of awesome gameplay if
you're interested so be sure to check
that out thanks for watching
[Music]
you